so that porn king a good one he he was a
surprise to many people what in the ease
that have jumped out sent you that did
he he didn't know but he has told me
that a very very big porn site are
interested in sponsoring the hot cast so
I was yeah I wish had Niels John hand
show you got longer you've got long got
lined up yeah you're gonna I'm injured
my nails
Merry Christmas everyone new year yeah
since when did you want to drive it the
class two glasses [__] out myself
guess we're doing that why you put two
I've got Thank You Harry
let's though in the way so oh you're
gonna where's mine I've got right okay
this is what it's like every week do you
want to pop it Oh Merry Christmas to all
the true jolly podcast subscribers
rented room okay now we see how much
alcohol he's ever drunk oh you poor in
it alright these glasses actually pretty
good for pouring it because they get the
rid of the bubbles anyway doesn't matter
who gives a [__] it's gonna be a good
day today con here you go
should we do it like they're doing the
American bars and your savings we have
enough fuck-ups on this so yeah come on
come around and you can choose with us
are you gonna cheers with us yeah you're
really the third guy aren't you on this
pot but um don't see the profits so
it'll be right we're not gonna say that
legally you know I mean
yeah - Cheers Merry Christmas lads
Merry Christmas those fun Merry
Christmas guys mm not too bad a
room-temperature champagne when we run
out yeah of course
cuz the porn king also sent me this so
what should we start with sort of a
reflection on some of these podcasts
we've done later yeah I guess the
biggest one is Jay from The Inbetweeners
a big turning point he's gonna he would
like he's like the least celebrity
celebrity of hers and he was really a
great interview that you know he's one
of those lads I just like they're just
sit and play games with and I got I went
and watched his gaming channel I've not
watched I've subscribed but I'm washing
do i watch it I just wanted to play
games against them and have a laugh with
him right
I'd like I just want to chill with him
general I mean he's a great chill guy
such a nice wad I mean he was the and he
was not only that I think he had quite a
good perspective on everything yeah
groaned around it I like that and he
didn't say anything offensive and his
Tom Cruise was incredible his Tom Cruise
impression was amazing what about the
porn king did that surprise you it
surprised me was like I thought he we we
were going to be interviewing when you
said to me the actual faketaxi pedo
pervert no right now he's not a poodle
but yes very not the same to be the
brains behind all of this [__] is far
more interesting than a guy who just
[__] women yeah I mean we've all [__]
women - defines all old porn companies -
different kinds of brains I guess is
what you said yeah focus the brains out
with them and actually what really
freaked there's at the end was when he
just totally opened up and was like yeah
actually this year yeah but to go
through that and you just wouldn't
expect that from the porn king would you
would you I wouldn't have expected it
but when he said it didn't surprise me
do you know what I mean would you get
the norm for a good hour and a half by
that point so like but the the reason it
didn't surprise me was not cuz I thought
you look like an unstable guy
not you him hmm talking to him in this
not imagine you or him
I'm imagining of him all those million
I've always wanted to be that yeah porn
king um
he's done [__] waste my time on
YouTube anyway
yeah in many ways it's the same by the
way you get in [__] um it's he's in an
industry which I think isn't soulless
but also isn't the most fulfilling
industry
he's obviously struggled with the
divorcement a lot of women feel
fulfilled in the industry I think they
are filled I don't think a fulfilled I
think he also struggled a little bit
with some of the emotional side of it
where like the divorce from his wife I
think he still felt there was a bit of
guilt maybe left over than that and then
also the kind of well not only that once
you reach the top of the well and and a
lot of people feel like this it's like
watch me motivation to get up in the
morning know what what cuz there's no
challenge now he's had his company
saying that's it he just cashes the
check every week boom do you don't but
do you think that is the top I guess
that's the top of the business mountain
it didn't strike me bit it's become
about this you become about the money
and the success and you convince
yourself that that's the goal in life
and that is the true meaning of why
you're here excessive to be this guy
when you become that guy and you still
don't feel complete well then what the
[__] do I do now I've got yeah you
certainly I think I've got seven kids
some [__] multi-millionaire I'm
establishing me industry and maybe I'm
still searching you know I mean and that
will click this bit up after you snapped
maybe maybe we knew he was gonna go cut
to this we knew any side way and then
before that robbie williams that was
that that was a great day that was a
real what great your mental that you'll
always have that or yeah no one can ever
take the fact that I was in Robbie
Williams house on my birthday yeah had a
lunch with Robbie his daughters lovely
and his son was really nice and she she
tells me he took us into their bedroom
like you know I mean it wasn't not in a
wine stain sort of thing no come on no
but it was like that's when you know you
really like trust you
to make us like
taking people on your kids is like the
serious yeah yeah yeah Sofer please and
also all those semen stains I mean using
a Fox's oh he stains the other cleaner
no chef though that chef though oh yes
yeah so when we were you ins this is
when you sort of have an idea of who Rob
is in your head but then when when
someone opens the door in you're like
who's that door opener and then it's
like there's the chef door and then
they're like he's got so many people
that's when I was like it wasn't a door
open it just all right please manager
but like let's be honest here I realized
like the guy's a boss like he is that
are really quite literal level like 200
million net worth apparently something
like that like do you look that up or
did he just did he whisper you know when
you go through the house the thing is
people get confused into thinking all
pop stars are around about worth the
same amount and then that's when you go
into a house I'd lighten you're like he
sold a [__] on a rack Rita Ora's worth
so much more yeah he's doing live two
hours and all the rest of it cause
they're well they're the moneymakers
puddin that's when I realized like from
a business point of view I could learn a
lot from him and and he's reached a
level that you know few people will ever
reach especially not not me very high a
very sort of cult status like an icon
he's an icon he took us into a room
remember that buck room it was like a
ballroom yeah just full of mirrors
he went sing along but there was a point
where we were in this ballroom type deal
where the [__] ceiling just went on
and on and on forever i leaked and i was
like a big house but then i took like a
little bit from me tally was bigger than
his and then he was like i was like my
daddy's bigger than yours so and then
he's like take it cinema room next let's
go to the cinema what no I don't need to
go out no no in my house yeah right that
was that was an eye-opener and the chef
brought us some amazing food it was just
and his garden was lovely this mistake
was
best steak I think I've ever had in his
house yeah yeah you cannot get better
than that
and also you weren't left quite walks
you're quite late along so the taxi
company who didn't and the Train I think
the train was also late well yeah train
was on time but because of the taxi that
didn't come I like a wit know the half
an hour I missed my train
okay I thought you're gonna say there
that in Newcastle the trains wait for
you the [__] should the bus starts
off looking power them ladies and
gentlemen Brian's going to be half an
hour late so we just need to hold this
train here and everyone just goes oh
it's just true Jordi's train cool not
like I can't go to the train station
though without taking pictures every
tomans do you like the memories right on
people yes mm um that's fine but then I
was alone in the house had you seen
Robbie Williams you have to use both
names
Robbie before that or was this the first
time he came out when he came out and
said hello to us yes you I'm we're
talking the new camera so not even
listened I'm listen he's got storm Z on
in his headphones yeah it's gone
straight to his head bubbles well you
did you meet Robbie before Lawrence no
right that was what was weird when I
went in Frank what was it like what
you're sitting there on your own before
I got there then no no we were sitting
there as a team so it's con me
Eliot and we started to do an e he kept
using the phrase podcast for the podcast
and I was like you really have watched
the podcast and and then he was like
let's get alone and I was like yeah cool
yeah cool and then and then his daughter
it was sat next to me at lunch and went
are you having lunch with us I was like
wow I'm really I'm beneath even you and
she was really sweet like she was a
really sweet little kid but you know her
mum's American he's English she had this
amazing like English American yeah yeah
and and I had steak and she turned to me
and went I'm vegetarian and like looked
a bit like dead in the oven I'm
vegetarian as if I'm supposed to get rid
of the steak because she's there like
disgusted with me a five-year-old was
judge surely killing an animal yeah yeah
yeah imagine you as a five-year-old had
met her what a what a conversation that
would have been cuz you are
chatty we would have made an amazing
podcast yeah at that age child's podcast
oh yeah that's the future Robby make it
happen no lose children no the thing is
I wanted to keep it quiet the fact that
we'd been talking in contact for months
before him because I wanted to have a
nice surprise - omitted the podcast but
like it's weird the world of celebrity
and when you meet someone who's that
high up on the ladder must have been
good for him
like for just little things like when I
was like oh he was emailing us saying I
was anyone who you'd like the interview
and I was like oh it would be a person
from the music world maybe someone like
a Simon Cowell or someone like that like
one of the real big wigs I need just
seen that back in block capitals aim
lower
no he was like yeah my kids go to school
with his kids do they
I was like just to be clear his kids
were really like some of the sweetest
kids I've met and well you've said that
quite a lot a little bit for you yeah
such it was sweet children yes I robbed
the child is it mouse yeah she wasn't in
the house she was a girl runs off the
witches you had to be in the first meal
which I was I think there are male
witches only were and wicked witches and
heat but the thing was that really
struck me was he was a really good dad
like he wasn't like you know you meet
some people and the dads are like yeah
good to see you son and the sons like
yeah cool well when you're not in touch
with your own mind and your own feelings
as robbers so it's impossible for you
not to be able to go there with your own
kids as well and be in touch with their
minds and that's up yeah there's not a
doubt I mean my indie but even just a
way is just to chat do you can tell
there's no divide between him and his
feelings and all of that where some
people well you see some dads are like
yes I'm like yeah they can't go there so
like his kids could just call out his
name and he was like I'm just in there
you know second living room and they and
they'd go to a second living room
they're all chill out and then they'd
always watching and they're all
thin and then he go great moments uh-oh
hello and then we get into a
conversation yeah there's one point we
were smoking outside his house and I was
just like was it bits I think it was it
was cuz I've done a lot of Amy Allen
with them and you still had a bit more
of the because you idolized him as a
child as a child I was a child no it's
off or was it a bit a little bit because
you very rarely get starstruck but would
you say you were a bit starstruck there
yeah but it really helped that we hugged
when we met
yeah it was just at ease doesn't he you
know what normally you meet a celebrity
in there a bit like in the same way as
did the dad thing where they're like
good to see a buddy and he was just sort
of really chilled out nice guy I love
I've said to me I don't like Robbie
Williams persona and I was like then
you're a [__] hmm because you don't
know him like I do
I honestly do in that podcast I've never
felt more relaxed in my in my history of
podcasts like yeah but a part of that is
because I've done so many of them though
but also the the being in contact all
the way up until the day of just I just
knew it was gonna be great and and his
dad was so lovely as well it was
probably my favorite podcast we've done
like yeah honestly it or at least top
three general I mean yeah we've got some
really good ones too I mean it's a
catalogue to be honest there's so many
go back and watch them but that is
definitely tops 3 yeah if it was in many
ways it's funny cuz actually the guests
almost looked like the evolution of man
and Robbie's like there well what's
funny is there's a few people who have
been in contact with censor to get on
and they're like well I'm no Robbie
Williams and I'm yeah as if every one we
get is like really helpful that getting
more of that stain no I would be last
week Gary Barlow I'll definitely be in
I'll definitely be in touch with Rob to
try and pull a few strings hopefully in
the future he's watching who can you get
with me you know
let us know also though I think it was
just lovely to get invite someone's
house even no matter who it is it's just
nice go to someone's house and sort of
be welcomed yeah I mean I don't think
you'll see many other interviewers
invited to Rob's house know what I would
have found what can I say we've changed
we've changed you've changed through
Geordie I've seen a couple of people say
that because for those who don't know
I've had issues because I've been moving
studio up north where Cormac as many
football hung all of us and I want to
get back to doing Lord's the next season
but you combine that problem with in the
robbery podcast it's a forgotten his
roots yeah doesn't care about what me
what me Adam doesn't care anymore
football you know I mean doing five our
live streams on the weekend so you
really are making it I mean I'm a mother
I'm not putting enough effort in you
know I mean who even cares Slater
Robbie's toilet flush was incredible one
flush old life it was you know it's not
watching Niagara Falls his toilet HUD
buttons painted on the ball of the
toilet and I'm literally like you're
pissing on patterns here this is Mendel
yeah
when you went round that it seemed like
every staircase door it just led I was
like Willy Wonka I was [__] Chocolate
Factory and everything just it went on
and on you know Jim music studio [__]
ballroom a cinema and it was it was just
it went on and on and on and then there
was some lovely girl who stopped us in
the middle of the house and Robbie said
oh I mean obviously she worked for him
yeah [__] knows what she did beautiful
girls like and these women are just
wandering around your halls wandering
around mmm I tell you what though I
don't think I built the handle it the
way he does like because one thing I've
noticed about Robbie know what you have
done if you if Robbie and I were your
guests and you saw a woman in the hall
would you just go [__] off floods give
me a minute walk off ya know one thing
I've noticed right and I have to say
this we've had some we've had people
with a lot of funds on the show before I
think Robbie is the most famous guy that
we've had aa [__] now but some people
disputed that were like well ksi he's
got a lot of fans in it and then you've
got some people like Alan Shearer I was
pretty famous you know and things out
and I was like who
has 130,000 people turn off for them in
concert is there anyone else we've done
that no Alan Shearer though did play
Wembley no but the point is he - you're
robbing the point is is what I'm trying
you know what I mean Robbie as 130,000
people there for him him alone not a
team not anything spying 70 odd million
records or whatever it is and one thing
that I realized that come with that was
an army of his fans right and when
Robbie Williams fans tweet you and he
you see like Angels lyrics tattooed on
their arms like you you realize it's
another level of nothing that anyone
else we've had has anything like the
hero status of the worship that he gets
and like then I realized he's had like
20 years of this now and like I know
he's totally used to it but like there's
girls like literally treating me and you
can tell they're like just thirsty for
Robbie Williams like even now like
non-stop all they do all the names on RW
on Twitter [__] pictures of him just
obsessed with them like that's mud to
the level that he's had it's it's mud if
you're obsessed with Robbie and or Brian
in the same way put T G in your name
this Christmas and if you're obsessed
with Lawrence McKenna poor LM Elam's ck
oh yeah I don't see care just if anyone
will do it he'll be true your D quotes
and that make me happy that they go oh
you're any quote should we get him on it
what poem how it actually amazing
because he can we have a picture of him
first on I'm a bit worried he might be
some sort of little because some
youtubers hide their faces and it's for
good reason but then maybe this well no
I'm just saying generally nothing but
I'm worried about AG courts I I'm you
know how old is he where is he he is he
locked away in a basement you know I
mean let's find out about this kid only
someone who posts podcast quotes could
be locked away in a basement in nor
definitely
so what what's your idea on being
friends with because it's sort of weird
isn't it you are actually kind of quite
getting quite close now with someone
called Robbie Williams
that's quite an unusual friendship isn't
it one thing that the Alan Shearer our
podcast taught us is to block out status
and what people have achieved went know
when when you're sitting chatting with
them because as people as fun as it is
when someone admires you for about five
minutes
eventually you just want to talk about
what's been happening on the news or
whatever has been happening in the world
that's why when we don't want someone
constantly sucking you off because of
what you've achieved that's why when we
first get into the podcast room I just
have let Brian get it all out just sort
of I thought you it was amazing on the
weekend thanks Angus I just keep going
so so here was the moment that I
realized how mad it was I told about
that moment I had years before I met
Robbie on the podcast and and I'll get
on the train I grab back the Newcastle
and my mates with him though he's a good
lad I like him he's really a nice bloke
north and then I sort of totally you
forget a little bit about what they've
achieved sort of thing and then I put my
headphones and I thought I'll just put
one of his songs on because I've spent
the day with him they'll be nicer not
quite like I quite like my favourite or
be with him song of interested DJ rock
teacher you know what I feel was good
mine is no regrets no regrets is a good
one it so many goods millenniums also
read no but no regrets as the lyrics are
really good I think yeah anyway so I put
me headphones in and I put angels on cuz
I thought let's play the love song and I
won't long like that's a good one and it
just hit there's all of a sudden like
[__] me yeah that he's this guy that I'm
made so if now as well and he did
alright this song and then I was I what
a life he's had yeah and now he's met me
onwards and upwards so in a way no is it
the only way is up
you can't it you can it here or worship
everyone yet you just have to treat
people like people because even
celebrities who
who do greatness they're just [__]
people and the Shira effect podcast was
the most stress I've ever been and
because I idolized him
I I wanted him to be me [__] dad
growing up like just literally couldn't
have worshipped anyone more so before I
come in this room when we did the
podcast with him I remember sitting
there thinking just treat him like a
[__] blob otherwise you're gonna [__]
this up royally and then after that I
thought all right I've actually achieved
something they did a really good podcast
with someone I've idolized from now on
just treat every situation the same but
with Robbie it was different because
Robbie so personable and another email
them for that long I could I didn't even
have to try to be relaxed I was [__]
horizontal general I mean and all that
weed if all the jade seah givers we
didn't smell you Robbie Williams that's
the next one
Eliot I did actually come up with a lot
of questions when I was listening back
to the book I was like you know just
stuff that I wanted to ask him now I did
as well looking back thinking you know
what was Leslie yeah I mean we were
there for about what seven eight hours
or whatever was that you in there but in
three hours it shows you can't even
cover his life yeah at all and not even
getting nearer yeah because there's like
there's so much more to ask isn't there
although other sirens stopping um so
yeah I just added more about him as the
family man and things that that move him
forward so the next one I want to do I
want to do that so I really enjoyed his
his dad coming in at the end because he
was like this and these lovely is
exactly classic entertainers that were
so many people so just one podcast with
his dad yeah but I feel like what all we
need to do is just go welcome and he
just go so I was in the bar the other
night amazed off and he's like he does a
two-hour set and then we just go such an
entertainer yeah I've since then I've
been watching more of him and his dad
singing together yeah watch your name I
looked him up
it's quite nice [__] off mum
he's trying his best Easter Stronach
honestly quick those ubers really do a
good job though I've been hovered a lot
of issues with uber lately they're
really paying off out yeah they really
pissed me off why because they're [__]
most of them don't have a [__] clue
where anything is in London and I'm
[__] sick of them such one cuz you
have you don't get us wrong you get the
odd one who's lovely chat lead guy she's
just happy [__] doing his job not a
problem but then so many one guys that I
just feel like stretching the car off
and walking away I thought all you do do
you tell tell us about it pal wait sorry
he just said that to you because he was
in traffic and that right there anyway
things say though he was pissed off
that's a really weird stuff as well did
you give him a five stars did I [__] I
don't even wrote them I've got better
things to be doing than written about
drivers just a little click [__] them
and if you agree you both get five stars
and that raises your rating which I know
still annoying but I've met a couple of
nice ones but you saw many of them are
just useless [__]
ideally what woody but Boober be like
then because I think it's not a terrible
service sometimes you get in the car and
she's not weather with nor London just
nor London they've got an iPhone why do
they need some of them call work the I
for month know that's a problem you're
right now ways they have something
called ways which doesn't really I feel
like you a little bit harsh on you big
drive yeah I'm working what do they work
so hard just the nice ones I do yeah I
like the nice ones yeah you want to talk
about Antoine Griezmann
what is there to say about that what is
there to say about a man who will act up
no but the point the point is what we're
just seeing about Robbie is we've got
someone who it's got people who worship
Him who really should be in a bubble
he's got people that he's much richer
than Antoine Griezmann for [__] sake
and not for much longer Barcelona and
let's be honest
yet still keeps himself grounded in
self-aware and then there's Antoine
Griezmann who thinks it's okay as a
professional footballer who just because
you've got the whole or trusting
artistic and people might not get this
they might not think I'm a basketball
player if I'm if I'm working a full
uniform so what can I do to sort of fill
in the blank
yeah get me the sharpie hand em I'm
laughing only because of how dumb this
guy must be like literally how offensive
it is these actions would you say
and we run I do this other football
podcast obviously you and I do the
football thing so we're quite in that
sphere of football and a lot of people
tweeted me to say it's not racist silly
I don't think he is racist I think he's
just very stupid think he's done
something racist I don't love it it's
racist I don't know I don't want to put
that label on a bit offensive as the
word I would use to people obviously on
a very fundamental level the thought of
blacking up wearing to pay tribute to
someone is it is quite a sweet idea
do you know what I mean by that in that
he obviously doesn't mean into a fun
people and wants to go the whole hog
yeah
but also in the context of probably not
great in the context of history waking
ups terrible because back in the day
people used to do it yeah and also
people see it in some ways I guess is
there's an element of cultural
appropriation there or sort of co-opting
ideas one thing a lot of the people were
responding was my skin colour is not a
costume and and that's quite that's all
you need to say really though as soon as
he hears that yeah I can't believe he
even was allowed to get it how many yes
men was he have around him to allow this
to even huh isn't even better thing is
he didn't even delete the tweet straight
away tweeted something else in defence
it was I said don't take me seriously
friends don't take you seriously it's
just a tribute I was like you're not
[__] Jack Black the greatest
attribute and then he deleted it and
said he was very sorry to anyone who's
offended that my favourite picture did
you see Harry's picture wrote a pack
yeah
yeah oh he's one of the funniest
tweeters gunman blacking up and most of
the people who tweeted me were not the
thing is I think in a certain part of
the world we see that as offensive and
we understand why Spain is part of that
part of the world Spain is a slightly
different culture to England I also
think even on quite where we are other
no it's much warmer no you know what I
mean yeah regards to England culturally
I don't think it's quite the same but
then he's got the French Connection as
well so he loved he has I don't want to
say here's black friends you know what I
mean he knows not to do this you think
so you'd also thinking that someone's
taking that picture and gone that's a
great idea
yeah Evette reset the phone up really
well on the side what you if there's
girls out there who are sort of wanting
to take pictures for the boyfriend if
you just put your phone I don't black up
no your boyfriend's got a thing for
black girls you're you're [__] if
you're not black you will eventually go
that way maybe committed young man but
if you want to take pictures of yourself
video record I just pop the video cord
on put the phone on the on the side
maybe on a bench on it put your harlem
globetrotters this is right that right
pause for him right you know in the in
the uniform not in any uniform and then
stop the video screenshot the pause that
you want to send to them and they've
you've got your selfie because a lot of
girls they feel like they've got a pause
and the mirror or whatever you don't
have to do that you know I mean his
video not lower the quality it does but
you know as men we want the pause we
want don't we right so are you quite a
director of poses sometimes you just
want what you want as a Riga point and
if I want Harlem Globetrotters shirt on
a girl band while she's bending over you
showing her a stand you've got to do
that in a sporting scenario yeah what
after slamming down I must admit if a
girl did put on it like a Newcastle
shirt or something like that and like
pours I would I think I'll be quite hot
oh yeah absolutely yeah I mean nights of
[__] [__] ironic ooh that was one of
the few things I used to like about
soccer right yeah so you know
when they brought out the soccer at that
some names that had like a really bug in
soccer a cool right it that was a
horrific part of the show it was the
only way I were to [__] kept his love
joy just goes and then she saw strutted
around all girly but she was just
usually the page tree girl or whatever
you're not I mean were they a lot of
them are I mean some of them are real
fans obviously as they went on but a lot
of unfortunates know what's a frame is
if we get the big sponsorship deal from
the big porn site right we have to have
just one of them coming every week
modeling and then and you're and I'm
sitting there just in the background oh
god I would honestly because not the
thing is though it's like what if I end
up in the pawn circle I would love to do
that what sorry what's the porn circle
the circle of trust
I'm thinking gone to an avian award
what's that which is the biggest porn
Awards it's like the Oscars for the porn
lock anal vaginal anal season it's like
they're an award that gets given up but
I think what does that sound for con
would you be or for coming and just
holding the camera and I go around you
don't have to come because I know it's
not really your scene an interview
although Ponca pawn girls and that miss
away would not be great though
or we could do a documentary maybe for
the channel a documentary on pornography
isn't interest I think that would be
cool as for yeah we've got the good side
the bad side what is your opinion on
porn without it my life wouldn't have
been as bearable of times to bring yeah
points did you would you say would you
go as far as to say porn saved your life
no but it's just it's an essential for
me right but the thing is finds
essentials no but the thing is as men
and this is the thing there's some girls
you just shouldn't [__] right they'll
drag you in to issues right right we've
seen that on some recent podcast some
girls are gonna be problematic for you
and cause moms
and as I found out since some podcast
recently some relationships are ideal as
they may see him why you looking me dead
in the eye when you say because I'm
trying to kill get a message across to
you write about another podcast which
one anywhere any weird anyway is happily
married moving on right so some girls
aren't right for you and they may cause
problems for you
Robbie's normal yeah you couldn't and
the way around that is we all have urges
as men and sometimes sometimes I
remember special I was younger I'd be
sitting there and I think I'm horny I'm
gonna pick the phone up and dial the
skill even though I know a whirlwind of
[__] is gonna [__] come with it you
[__] and then afterwards you know
you've got the headaches and all the
issues porn is a good way of getting rid
of those sexual urges without havin to
get yourself involved with certain girls
you find it as satisfying as real sex no
no [__] way yeah but sometimes I can
prefer it just because of the lack of a
headache afterwards no it's you know
that there's a little video sometimes
they'll send you after you've watched
the porn of the girl just complaining at
you just to make it feel more real what
I mean I'll text you intermittently
where are your names I'll be in brutally
honest I wanna [__] a girl for a good
[__] good hour you know really blow
the [__] brains out of it and I've
got the energy and I really really need
to I want to feel like I can't [__]
anymore but then some names just a quick
one so all I've got time for on the day
John I mean and then you're starting a
business I mean it's gotta be done you
can't be taking hours and you got to
keep the blood flow below the belt but
you also have you have to work hard play
hard work hopefully I'm just drinking a
lot of else yeah me too so a one
basically really takes care of a lot of
problems you know I mean you can't
always be spending time with women you
need it just not if you want to be
successful ironically one as I've seen
as losers but I guarantee the more
successful men are probably wrong and a
lot more than their [__]
you think well yeah because you're not
spending all your time with women and
[__] are not so many many miserable
relationships recently a mouth god I
love as well the amount of them that go
yeah you all really when you get older
you'll understand yeah I'm a dude who
regrets a lot you know I mean mm-hmm
give him Robbie Williams some no regrets
if he'll wait no regrets you give the
gift of Robbie Williams this Christmas
day only her wash your favorite Robbie
Williams album kritis hurts yeah best of
esta probably really honor for me as
well
slash now that I called you know I
realize but I watch her out I didn't
really praised him for his music or the
choice then that was actually a really
good song wasn't it
do you think we can get Robbie's listen
to knows I just about get me press
release about my get up race and I go
[__] beanie renegade master that was
so good did he do renegade master dick
danila yeah that was a really good song
yeah I'm actually gonna just download
that now cuz I was uh but yeah basically
you got to keep one in June and I mean
that's that's the way forward right yeah
put that on a t-shirt
have you added any more ideas for
t-shirts yeah I've got [__] um I ran a
game we're sorting a business so cheers
for that do you ever worry that your
iPhone's listen integer do you ever
worry your iPhone's listening to you no
good me either
we're starting a business next year
you'll see can we can we reveal anything
not even anything no that's what I love
about it is the people that we're coming
for you will not see us coming we're
gonna Titanic the [__] one of the guys I
had a meeting with last night
Jordi ahead he's like I'm a second he
says I'm sick of these other companies
who are ahead of us and we're feel like
we're just like you know children all
the youtubers just getting into
lifeboats and you're just carving your
way down the side of the [__] YouTube
Titan movie Oh suddenly we see you know
other fan cam channels on doors floating
in the sea Robbie's holding on as hard
as he can
claud's on the door obviously and he's
going there's not enough place on the
door Robbie there's not enough space and
during Robbie's I I'm pretty sure he's
holding the mic with one hand I'm pretty
sure there is Claude I'm pretty sure
there is we don't want to do anything
that'll add TV for the record we're not
we're not getting into the fun come
business now if it was just a joke it's
still a funny joke that Robbie's in the
water in a full I don't imagine Robbie
really no best swimmer and still in a
full actually Robbie is Robbie's quite a
powerful guy I've seen him boxing yes I
don't think that makes for a good
swimmer okay honestly I see him Robbie
some reason I follow up I subscribe to
Robbie's man that Robbie channel her I'm
seeing him that's got some of the best
videos on Robbie's there in the water
Claude do you think we could open one of
the No do you think we coulda done
better in steering the ship - it has pod
Robbie
well these cons [__] off there's a high
terror alert in London a moment and
there's a yeah really
hmm I was filming yes and then I'll have
a brick it's [__] Christmas I was
filming yesterday
coming to it well that's why I guess who
the [__] radicalized is Christmas
autonomies all these little elves out
there just furious strike the deliver
footman presence now I was thinking I my
joke was more that the elves were
radicalized delivering bombs yeah God if
something happens in the meantime so I
was having a business anyway and I'm
really looking forward to next year's
gonna be good it's gonna be called
Amazon Prime we've got something [__]
sake
shut the [__] window mitt is it not
already shot are okay still it's still
gonna be pretty bad well we'll wait
until it's finish us irony for these
[__] hoods yeah we still we have
interior logo so we're starting a
business don't look too happy about it
it's gonna be called Google now so we
can't see nothing nope and that's what I
love about it Titanic people knew about
totally yeah they knew about the Titanic
but they didn't go that will sink yeah
that's true yeah if anything and this is
the best bit about it and that's why
it's such a good analogy to know what
they said look that's the unsinkable
ship and there are people in YouTube
going we are unsinkable and then we come
along go know mmm and suddenly 15 holes
in your chest
hmm so one person who thought that they
were unsinkable unbeatable or whatever
Tyson Fury
you know how we had that that lard on
who likes to jump off of buildings and
skate yeah and you said be careful you
inspire and then out of nowhere someone
died in Japan did you hear about that it
was China so so right okay not Japan
that's the stick I usually make not you
I've only had I've been told the second
hand so obviously you know they told me
Japan obviously in the video or so I
read the Sun obviously in the video what
I'm dying so he was a youtuber can I
kind of show you it because it really
[__] me up watching it and I need you
to say it great okay
will you watch it I know can you explain
more Tupman the building is it like a it
looks like a skyscraper right on the
edge
oh god this is gonna be already wrong
heart is moving out my chest why is he
doing this why is he cleaning the
building IIIi think he might be sort of
getting his grip what he's trying to do
is prove sort of or whatever here this
really [__] me up though what what is
he doing here this is such a terrible
that's a terrible idea
he's lowering himself over the side of
the building right off the side of the
building he's gonna lose hung by his
hands and but he seemed quite confident
yeah he does like a Palo we can't see
his face nobody does a pull-up here and
he seems quite assured that he's got
himself my heart's beating so fast
I know I smell horrible you're gonna
lose it and you so then why he's doing
then he pulls himself back up and he
starts doing pull ups to prove his
strength yeah and now he wants to get
back up and he's struggling he's
struggling somewhat now he can't pull up
his strengths gone his arms have gone
nice panicking this is live streaming
witness analyzers on the livestream he
is on sonic he's gon get back up
and dead why he was I'm happy
no it just it really [__] me up when I
watch I was like and then and then I
thought of nightscape straightaway after
that and I thought myself like inside of
a bathing no but I mean nightscape is a
smart lad you'd hope you wouldn't take
that kind of transport I've seen him
take chances before and you think
yourself when people do this [__] like
how can you have sympathy for one that
it goes wrong because you know the risk
involved it's like it's like playing
poker and losing all your [__] money
like that is part of the game you can
you can be here or other zero and the
more times you do that sort of thing the
more likely it is that one day you're
not gonna land it and you are gonna fall
but it also feels less likely because
you've done it more so I guess in the
mind yes you're mine and I guess but it
is a little bit like playing that ruler
isn't it Russian roulette yeah but then
also I guess that part of part of the
point to counter that would be some
people are very experienced some people
go if the whole life of doing that never
fall never even think about it and never
have that problem but that one person is
gonna have that problem he's in quite
young that was quite a young looking
body I mean you looked about here - 9 -
yeah it looked very sort of he looked
like a young guy but I can't help but
feel like it was like almost suicide by
stupidity death by stupidity they didn't
suicides a little bit of I thought were
suicides when you tried to kill herself
rather death by stupidity they
definitely didn't help themselves
yeah I mean what again though there are
Daredevils in the world I feel like when
society's small enough then we can
attribute we can sort of it's it's you
can sort of rationalize things but
there's enough people in the world but
actually people are gonna do stupid
things and some people are Daredevils
some people aren't
I feel like terrible about it now like
obviously feel terrible about the
situation and I'm also a bit like well
oh you're [__] I do it yeah the other
day I devil you put yourself over the
side of the building and you knew what
the risk was yeah I guess when you're
young you just feel
vincible innocence and you don't die
[__] freak me out early i was a
imagine the moment when he let go though
because he also jumped away from the
building
maybe i think he do you think he was
trying to aim for another ledger so
maybe that was it though do we know that
person died it was in china so you don't
know well it's on the news he's in
Jurassic Park something who sir
but in China so we don't know nobody
definitely died because of something the
news that he died then uses night before
yeah maybe the news had a lot of lies a
lot of lies people have been tweeting
inserting what they want us to talk
about what's your biggest achievement of
2017 yeah it's a nice thing to say that
there's a lot of things to choose from
there yeah for me and you um we did half
a million subscribers on the channel
which is a really good thing and that
was me a.m. at the start of the year and
I actually thought it was a little bit
unrealistic and why we're actually
closer to 600 now than 500 so that's
good I don't know it's it to sort the
out just looked at how many subs I was
getting and I thought if I do everything
I want to do I'll probably be around
about 500 if I'm lucky and that was me
thinking that would be really good so
that's good I'm proud of that I don't
care about subs anywhere near as much
now because I noticed that I think when
you saw Jason subs your content becomes
more about getting new people to watch
rather than just making good content
we've had some really good guest on the
podcast with any couple of big names
with any Steven Troy's even tries Robbie
Williams Bobby Williams Alan Shearer I
think I think the Alan Shearer one was a
real moment because it was like my hero
on my podcast with me and I think
everyone shared in that moment if you
were a fan of me our friend or anything
like that
because everyone knew like this is a guy
who's come from zero to now he's got
[__] match of the day pundit and
old-time primary course crown his pawns
that was that was a real moment I think
what we've just done before the years
out is big we're now shareholders in a
company and we're moving much bigger and
were in my future plans so the coral
deal the coral deal will shout out to
coral and Elliott now the coral deal was
because that was a company took a chance
on us and we proved that we are capable
of doing everything we think we are and
really in terms of structure that deal
what people don't know is like most
people who get deals like that on
massive companies or big youtube
companies and we did that just may in
you with the help of our friends at
formidable but we landed the deal just
not such brave little bison on my own
too so we landed that Omar on to you did
also put out a video beginning of the
year did the holiday so that 17 the
football holiday was my favorite video
of 2017 that we've including a podcast
so excluding the Robbie Williams yeah
that was me favorite thing that we've
made and I wanted to make more of those
schedules hasn't yet made finding stuff
up but 2008 you know I think we're gonna
make a lot more of those with what we've
got in mind I'm gonna meet willing
Steven after this we're gonna be so
paste our heads yeah William sleeve and
I'm coming we save this when they arrive
and we can give them a little bit for
Christmas know we'll just buy more in a
bar that's the great thing about alcohol
yeah so I think two and a half hours
until sunset for the for the year I know
this is a shambolic pod at a it's the
end of the year we're having a drink
it's Christmas it was bad before we
start drinking that's the world oh yeah
for me personally I think that the thing
that was the biggest moment was Alan
Shearer on the podcast for me because it
I never thought I would I believe in
myself but sometimes it just doesn't
seem real one [__] like that happens to
us because at the same time I'm still
that [__] eight-year-old who worships
this guy within myself so that was the
moment where I was like actually I can
do I can do anything I set me my new or
not anything but almost anything like
what what's not doable if I can do that
do you know what I mean so that that
gave me the self belief to think I don't
do anything I can't do anything for me
but you can't climb building in but yeah
I don't I don't want to claim a buzzer
yes but that gave me the self belief saw
that when I did the Robie podcast I was
so confident and calm and now when I
step in rooms
nothing can intimidate me because I
nailed that interview yeomen what
woodrugh be gay so that was that was me
that was a really great year but that
was the moment where I feel like oh [__]
me this is a milestone and a half that I
think people will look back at that in a
couple years time and be like wow that
was a bit of a turning point for us mmm
and net neutrality what do you think
about that well you'll have to explain
there was exactly what your definition
of it is because it gets a bit confusing
to be honest really yeah okay um the my
definition of net neutrality I think the
broad definition of net neutrality is
the freedom of information to flow as
people without being monitored not maybe
not without being monitored but without
being capped so the whole idea that
they're selling it within America at the
moment is net neutrality woman that or
taking away net neutrality means that
now service providers will be able to
strangle certain things so if you want
YouTube you'll have to pay extra to be
able to get YouTube through if you want
Netflix you have to be extra to get
Netflix through your they're gonna do on
the porn on your number
and they'll probably do it on the porn
yeah [__] cons mainly it'll be mainly
the heavy ones a big horn site they're
really neat to sponsor so it kept more
people below but the point is that net
neutrality is actually really important
outside of the market as well and net
neutrality is actually important to just
let let information go where it needs to
go because it it helps with
democratizing society it helps to
because if you can't afford to get
YouTube then what happens that doesn't
feel fair to me do you know what I mean
YouTube should be accessible for
everyone as far as I'm concerned the
Internet should be accessible through
every we really need to be accessible
yeah and so it's threatening part of
what we want what we want to go this
YouTube will go and touch to be fair by
what I've heard but it's the it's the
other [__] but they're gonna try and
[__] anti-government a lot I think
predominantly it'd be use for that it
will predominately be also used for that
but also I think people don't buy it as
our stuff doesn't and it won't really
stop it it'll start as a protection
thing and then eventually they'll just
strangle it more and more and let's also
saying that neutrality is also a good
idea in some ways because it allows
information to go at any speed where it
needs to go the idea of not having that
neutrality is also a good idea because
it means you can have maybe a cheaper
iPhone plan for your kids or for you so
if you use YouTube more on it on one
thing and then you won't pay just for
YouTube but you never use I don't know
Instagram you don't have to pay for
Instagram Instagram could be a separate
part of the package yeah that's not the
worst thing either so you don't pay for
Instagram but you pay for YouTube you
pay less for Instagram because you don't
use it as much I think that's how
they're marketing out learning is true
net neutrality need to mean something I
think it's quite an ideological but the
original idea of the internet was live
at the [__] alone freedom of me live at
the [__] freedom of movement
information and it's not you and I or
directly effect I think it effect poorer
people more because they can't afford as
much and therefore it will affect us
because we make we time for poor people
let's be honest we appeal to the
everyman
that's what we're here for you know me
yeah
the everyman theatre is every man and
woman yeah you know mean good we're not
making content will changed you know no
I am the everyman yeah you know a woman
a woman someone's saying we should talk
about YouTube rewind or do you know what
that is you seen that it's a yearly
video done by YouTube which is
absolutely CAC and no one gives a [__]
about I mean that's you that's a real I
started off you guys Milnes react to
them because they know it's at the
YouTube basically oh we'll set the trend
this week if you tag your video this
it'll go up right yeah
no one cares case I was really good in
it a couple of other people were good in
it
throwing gel around I don't really think
I don't really like the poor brothers so
I don't dislike him I just don't watch
him so I don't really care do you know
what I mean for him fighting fair and
just like him a little bit do you know I
actually sat and watched one of the one
of their interviews that was done it's
The Breakfast Club didn't interview with
with Jake Paul no I thought we said you
know is that I thought it was a bit of a
dick in the past but I'm gonna give this
kid a chance here and I thought one
thing that came across is business-wise
he is he's got something he's young he
is switched on I feel like do you not
feel like it's a bit like the Alfie
thing like want I took an instant
dislike to someone without actually
given them a chance and and and even if
I don't like their content or it isn't
made for me
I can appreciate someone who's
absolutely wrecking the industry
financially rinsing the industry yeah no
he's making a [__] mint yeah but I'm
trying to make [__] with a bit of
credibility and it's like I'm empty in
the sea with a [__] bucket why a lot
of people are over there just dumping
[__] [__] into it you know and and he
just conducts himself like a [__]
[__] doesn't need to be understood
that's part of the problem
I mean TJ parlors like I mean just
talking like that generally is a little
bit annoying yeah you know I mean what I
guess and I said a ban on the mayor
isn't [__] like that and it's like me
like you sound like a [__]
it's sort of works it's sort of works it
works because he comes across as the
douchebag jock you know I mean yeah at
the least favorite of all of the
characters in any movie and in any high
school sort of yeah yeah reunieron TV
American [__] and that's why people love
you why you're not a high school jock
what I'm Island
I don't know you're sort of the guy
inside the class of in high school grab
someone you go leave him alone
do you know what you leave him alone old
you know you know if I was any character
from a in my mind anyway the way I sort
of acted in my own self as from home
alone [__] you you [__]
the tarantula I guess in a high school I
never really fitted into the even though
I was I was quite strong or whatever but
you have a moment in high school where
you remember thinking really like what's
going on here I really like what's going
on here
like I feel like I'm life sort of coming
together know me I really struggled in
high school I don't mean in high school
I just mean in that time in general like
didn't have to be school related I mean
in those years cuz it a few times where
I think back to a time and there's a few
times where I think I felt really good
about myself at that point like really
sort of like life is coming together not
everything's coming up millhouse sort of
thing yeah but yeah not so genuinely and
I should actually say this and mean it
only in the last six month of I felt
that way about my life really and ever
ever ever in my life
wow I've always felt like a work in
progress
my whole maybe I'm hard on my soul I
don't know whatever
but I've never felt like there was a
moment where I felt like the questions
are asked on the podcast were better the
videos I made were a bit better and I'm
still not happy and entirely with
everything but I felt like I'm really
coming into my own
and I'm and Who I am I know and what I'm
doing and the way I'm going and the way
I've been everything makes sense and I'm
like
this home like I'm just like in me Prime
in this zone like I don't I don't feel
like I have anymore
real major problems I just have to keep
improving any way I can and make more
videos because I'm not doing as many as
I'd like to do make more the kind of
videos that I want to make but but I
know that I can do that with who I am
now I don't have to really work that
much on Who I am I just have to improve
is what I can but now me I'm just turned
30 and 29 and a half [__] years of
that I felt like I am NOT where I wanted
to be and I'm not what I want to do yeah
and I'm not there and in high school
even most I was more clueless and more
unaware of where the [__] I was gonna
end off so you weren't very happy in
high school nah nah you know I've I had
to pick a cliche a movie role of where I
was and what I acted like what's that
film called 10 Things I Hate About You
you know Heath Ledger in that movie
right I was that guy I wasn't really a
job but I could take here see
good-looking not not good thing but I
mean personality wise like I could
probably beat the [__] out of the jocks
but I wasn't one of the jocks yeah you
sort of like that that fringe guy I was
just on the outskirts could be mates
with any crowd but I wasn't in a crowd
Janome yeah yeah I was just there
yeah waiting for an end Bally's
but you weren't enjoying it no just
dwindling
I don't ever mean in the classes I mean
sort of like you know what about the
social bit did you I had a few moments
that were quite um you know once I went
to I got a girlfriend who didn't go to
my school and I went to one of her
school parties and her school was posh
our and nicer than my school so when I
went to this place and I was like dress
how handsome how he dressed I was
dressed like a child basically a chav
that charged have no we I call it Chavez
I thought all right yeah yeah we came up
with the word Chava
and then further so that when it became
chav yeah it's Chava anyway I was just
like what a Chava
just a film if you're from Newcastle
just take that in for a second okay I'm
just saying like it shot it sounds like
someone from London sort of being like
oh my God look at that Java look over
there guys
oh my God look at him anyway back to my
seller over yeah that is an acronym of
go wank
I was I was dressed yet I was just like
I wanna be hard boy
alright so FUBU jeans had Rockport's on
basically still say no more I have FUBU
jeans I am sniffing looked ridiculous
like I was hanging out I think I wore
like French Connection and [__] like
that like like the fragrance on it their
clients not like some of their clothes
and I see UK Rockport and Lacoste and
[__] right so we're talking anyway some
kid at the Point Blank is well some kid
at the party had kicked off and and I
just went over to him and escorted him
out of the party and just threw him out
the front door
and I hadn't really done anything other
than that I didn't hit her more but he
knew enough to not hit as I whatever but
like I try it but anyway I just remember
everyone looking others like you are a
[__] mate yeah yeah I hadn't even
done it I think it was just this thing
that I'd given off and that was quite an
amusing time because do you feel quite
happy in that moment you feel like yeah
my [__] yeah I'll [__] you all up on
[__] mania come on not not really I
thought it was funny that they all
thought I was this guy when I hadn't
even I don't even done anything like did
you throw him out of front door close
the door and go well that sorted that
what are you looking at a little a
little bit a little bit like that but
not quite I didn't say anything I was
very quiet and I only talked to my
girlfriend at the party I didn't talk to
anyone else she was she was very bubbly
and she was the chatty girl who would
talk to everyone and I was just like
sitting there and I wouldn't say
anything to anyone cuz I thought I don't
[__] know anyone here if people talk
to me I'll talk back but I was not
I have never craved attention and this
might sound mendel because people think
youtuber loves attention
but I don't crave it at all
but anyway that's you it's part of the
business is to get attention you crave
attention I think people mistake looking
for looking to make a connection with
people looking to express a message for
attention and the problem is if you want
to hate on someone it's very easy to say
you're doing it for it that was one of
the first things I got told a lot when I
started YouTube attention seeker by
people who didn't understand what I
needed views to make me [__] videos
you know but I don't know anything you
needed views I just think it's that
Europe
a lot of people want to put some people
down who want attention and it's very
there's a very fine line between being
attention seeking the thing is there's
actually nothing wrong with us seeking
people's attention no I think there's a
there's a way and means of doing it so
for example what I'm trying to do is
create a really good video that people
are gonna enjoy and and and put their
attention on that video also about me
there will be a lot of people that put
you down your life if you make a joke at
a party or you want to you want to have
positive attention from people and I get
it like attention is actually something
that's at a premium so most of the time
people say a lot you mean not only cost
money but it also is actually something
is quite valuable and we undervalue our
attention quite a lot we'll give
attention to loads of different things
we'll give attention stuff that actually
on a daily basis we shouldn't really pay
attention to Twitter's all about where
you direct your attention YouTube's all
about where you direct your attention
it's all about I need to scroll and
telephone something's worthy of my
attention I think maybe we don't value
that as much but what I'm trying to say
is I'm not the type like I I like going
out to be with me mates and getting
pissed but like since the YouTube thing
happened I don't go out anywhere near as
much because I know what people think oh
he thinks he's a [__] els that that's
not what I'm saying but in Newcastle see
there's not there's not not not even
that I'm a youtuber we're not even in
the list mate we're different we're not
even a part of celebrity with was
something else do you ever wonder what
people say but the point is I don't go
out to try because I'm and know what
it's like I don't hate oh yeah you know
I mean someone said to me yesterday
YouTube is the punk rock of
the media world and I'm not sure I agree
with that but we've been told that by
other people
sure I agree I don't think it's quite
that because you've got people like
Alfie deyes who are anything but
punk-rock but it is the alternative -
yes so punk-rock some Alfie deyes
they're just you know eating a bats head
and what I'm saying I mean it is the
alternative because people are getting
famous for reasons other than being in
TV shows and music and whatever TV shows
are now about getting famous
maybe the learns the lines are blurred
done' yeah little bit careless on what i
was trying to say is when I was younger
not I never felt like I am happy and
complete and home you know I mean I just
felt like I'm a rolling [__] stone if
you could talk that this now would you
change anything about that journey and
tell them anything or would you just
sort of let them keep going where
they're going I definitely required some
fatherly advice or some some moments
there do you think you got that not
definitely not I think I made a lot of
mistakes
what sort of fatherly advice would you
give yourself I mean yes I wouldn't want
to change the direction or anything that
I'll change too much but like I think
one of the things I was craving was
someone to put as any place a bit more
and you know be nicer to your mother and
things like that like when you're
frustrated or when a girl's pissing you
off I think one thing I did is I let
girls handle me a little bit more in the
early year 16 17 18
I got played a little bit I definitely
get hit no definitely not
I mean now whenever slapped you know no
never genuinely but I think the thing is
with me no girl ever wanted to play that
game yeah but ironically I don't know
maybe as I slap them on the are securing
sex but anyway well they love it but
sometimes what yeah I think we've all
been in their positions where you give
control to a girl and want one suck what
I realized was like
I'd never do that never ever do that now
why I just I'm in control of everything
in my life now I've become a little bit
of a control freak to be honest with you
there's I've gotten all that away about
it's a necessary like when you end up
yeah you got your own business and what
you want I'm all about getting what I
want out of life now and I thought
people might say that as selfish but I
really don't give a [__] and I don't
mean that in an arrogant way I just I
know that life short and you better
[__] try and make yourself happy
royally here do you think you have a
healthy relationship with women I've got
a really good relationship with my
mother and because of that I kind of
hold women to this unattainable standard
of perfection or muskers like when you
really hold her out Oh on a [__] on
top of a mountain on an island all on
our own nobody no person can even come
close to that but it's like so I guess
I've sort of mentally set a standard him
you had that women are never gonna meet
why why do you know because you know
that and you've just said that why do
you think then you hold that standard oh
do you think you want do you want them
to have meat no I've I've done that and
I'm trying to not do that anymore so
what I'm trying to say is you were just
blessed with an amazing mother yeah and
you need to not expect what problem is
when you grow up with someone who you
don't Kate
you think everyone's mom is like that
and then when you hit 20 and you're like
[__] no one else's mom treats them like
this you're actually really lucky and
you actually take your mother for
granted just totally mollycoddled
totally and just I was trapped like a
prince like you know like just
everything that could be done for us was
done for us
do you ever learn that other boys out
there now who were growing up who at
that same age you don't treat their mum
with
respect and sort of thing you don't know
how good you've got it no I do because
what I'm trying to do is I as I've
realized as I've got northern what a
lucky bus that I am is I try and pass
that message on especially when I say
younger lads there's a couple of lads
who are maybe younger brothers of my
mates who I have a word with when I say
the mouth enough to the mothers and I
say [__] stop it like yeah cuz the
thing is you never know what's gonna
happen you have to take the good people
in your life you have to appreciate them
you and and what I realized because
because I didn't have a dad who was in
the room at the time to say don't
[__] talk to your mom like that and
when I was having a bad day on me
hormones were [__] pinging cuz I was
bloody a teenage boy who just thought
sexually [__] frustrated I would lash
out and that a real I was no I was just
shouting yeah I hate yeah I hate your
like teenage boy does or teenage girls
do to their parents but now I look back
I doesn't think if I'd had a dad who'd
said don't [__] sweet your mom like
that I wouldn't have done it as much so
what I would try and say at that lad is
just appreciate what you've got more got
a great life perfect upbringing even
even though I've had a single mother it
was perfect than my eyes anyway but I
just let myself get out of control of it
so now as a man I'm realizing alright
this is what happened you should you
know so if I could go back to that that
16 year old boy I'd just give words of
advice that appreciate who's around you
more and don't let I'd say it hold me
Tamara more as well I think that is a
real issue enough and it's been like
chopping a tree down for me for the last
[__] 15 years is to get a grip on
this temper and I'm not there yet
but I'm really [__] trying I am like
really trying because it's such a
weakness in me personality and it really
is because it's like I've got all of
this like as in a business I work for
I'm
places me dreams are coming true and yet
if someone walks up to me in the street
and picks a fight with us
I would probably fight them right there
and then in the street and that is
stupid
yeah because you have if I get arrested
it's all tits everything you've worked
hard for it could be taken away you know
not you and that's all because some
random blog some random idiot is picked
a fight with us and I haven't had my ego
or my temper or whatever it is worn back
down and that is a thing I don't like
about myself because I'm not a UFC
fighter I'm just a [__] podcaster who
should let that go it doesn't prove
anything
it's stupid but in my head not only do I
want to fight them because they've
challenged me I want to really hurt them
yeah and I want to let them know to
never ever do that I can and it's like I
need to serve that part of us is always
being there particularly as a 16-yard so
just generally the anger just let the
cop the my anger in the last 15 years
has just depreciated massively and I'm a
much happier person but it's still
something I've got to work on and
especially I'd say that of me 15 year
old me what about you men what I say is
15 your meat mmm worry less just worried
less about stuff yeah but then that's
really I think that's really great
advice and I think it sticks in there
somewhere but I don't I think it's a
hold on it you know I think it also
helps to worry a little bit at that age
like it helps to go through those
emotions and get a hold on them because
actually I think if you don't interact
with those or you don't think of them as
real then you'll never you'll never work
it out and I think you have to go
through that in order to get to where
you want to be nice really terrible
yeah changing careers right I'm
apparently I'm a typical Aquarius
apparently eclair I don't know how true
these star signs things are but
apparently Aquarius chop and change
their jobs all the time
and I am totally like that
and that's why I used to be like [__]
I'm gonna be miserable here after a year
of doing my rows doin you like change
then so when you get into it rhythm
there would you be like I got a guy as
soon as I realized I was bored but then
the thing is the truth is I was just
unhappy but you didn't ever think about
that at the time I was just worried and
I was like [__] there's a [__] I bet I
get out yeah dude I mean I guess that's
yeah one thing that I did say one thing
I said to Robby it was I thought was
quite interesting at the time maybe
isn't interesting was a lot of the
people that we've had on have made
identities out of the problems that
they've had in their life and have
really built their life around me not
all of them some of them have actually
found really positive ways to deal with
the problems that they've done lately
I originally thought Sean Atwood
probably a real loser and got the nicest
things no no but when I first met him I
thought this guy's not gonna be a good
podcaster and and I judged him in the
wrong way cuz you the way he look not
the way look but also he presented
himself in his demeanor Olivia he comes
across as such an ordinary person and I
thought he is anything but ordinary
and I say that and I say I judged him as
a real loser because I realized he
wasn't if I thought he was a loser I
would I wouldn't maybe wouldn't say that
course you wouldn't say I don't actually
think Sean's a loser it's weird you know
this I tick people in when they become a
podcast guys yeah a little bit like the
I care about them after that because
they've done me a solid by coming on
this show and it's not easy to make this
podcast so when people give me that time
I don't take it for granted and and Sean
is one of the people I mean we've had
him on twice that speaks volumes with it
I mean listen I wouldn't totally have
him as five times yeah but not only that
he is such a nice block as well as a
wild man yeah but he's my type of
company like if you're doing if we're
doing
roundtable at the end of my life weights
like all the audio favorite podcast
guess I'm pretty sure Shawn would be on
that table you know or you know he'd be
freaking the rest of the table out maybe
on that table he's such a nice hood and
that's the funny thing but I still but
using some people have made identities
out of their problems that they've had
and I came not being one of them and I
guess I've really been thinking about
where we're taking the podcast because
I've really sat down and thought like
what would we actually do this
the amount of messages that I get every
week which are about people's problems
unlike and I realized when I was
teenager I thought I had so many
problems I didn't really have that many
problems
yeah if any any real problem any
problems which are sort of you know
actually gonna affect me in the long
term yeah I just I thought if you make
an identity out of the problems that you
have that can really help you in the
short term but I hope you don't do that
in the long term I don't mean you I hope
anyone when I'm saying you yeah because
if you make an identity out your problem
you always relate back to that problem
and in some way you're sort of tied down
to that anchor of that problem which was
there at that time yeah no no excited
what you mean and define it well who who
have something happened to them any yeah
and they never stop banging on about it
for the rest of their life and no no
sort of a there's always some way that
they can lead that back yeah and it's
not healthy because you don't want to be
defined by something bad that happened
to you and your life what you want to be
defined by is how you recovered from
that and grew and and went on to do
other things and and that's just part of
a story you don't want it to always be
about that let me try not to define
yourself by all those problems or try
not to define yourself in such a way
which isn't is comes from your negatives
and I understand everyone you know Gary
Vee and all these guys talking about you
know I overcome a prop I don't actually
IV so I don't know what he says um I
ever come up problems I hustle I do all
this I do all that I guess my advice my
that self would be like don't make that
identity out of those problems because
actually there's loads of other stuff
it's it's sad because everyone loves a
sob story or
a recovery from a sob story then we've I
leave I like because I fitted on this
podcast from although subside my other
not I admire when people pull the
[__] boot laces and then [__]
Gordon foot and kick ass you know what I
mean but equally there's a time to let
chick goes in there yeah I've got some
stories I've never [__] told and I
could [__] in city are enough everyone
[__] did it are pop right I'm not I
said not like you know I mean I like
people know and to a degree about me but
I'm more about where I'm going and what
I want to do Jenna and I mean and let
all that [__] go I guess even men like
I'm not saying I guess I'm thinking a
lot about where I'm going also where I
am right now like what that is how good
that is and like stuff tends to be way
better than you think is way way better
than you think is all the time I just
get a lot of miserable
I've getting a lot of messages lately on
Instagram which is people who say things
like you don't know how much of your
podcast is helping you and that and I so
it just blow your mind a little bit but
than you think
alright don't get too you know it's just
a podcast at the end here but also it is
nice to hear that but then you think
that he's hearing but at the same time
but then you think about what other
people are going through equally that
you're totally unaware of well people
are just chillin watching this right now
and then this they takin their mind off
of their stuff everyone's got stuff
we've all got stuff but what I think
you're saying is don't become that stuff
yeah and don't don't think that just
because we have a lot of guests and
you'd have a lot of guests who have had
really hard times that's the only way to
get to where you want to go know there's
some people who have perfectly got
upbringings and smush life and good for
them and it doesn't take anything away
from them because they haven't had hard
times
jinan I mean it's also interesting
because I was chatting to a few people
the other day about like Eastern Europe
and people used to be under the Iron
Curtain
like USSR that whole area and those guys
don't talk about being depressed they
don't talk about being low they don't
talk about any of those things because
those aren't definitions in that culture
no it's literally just like yeah you
probably sad you know and I think we do
make her a lot and we are bombarded
every day with articles about my
depression your depression how you could
be depressed how all these kind of thing
I'm not saying that's not important
there's an importance like that some
people are very severely depressed I
think we could just make less of it and
we could show people a more positive way
and I think if you show people at my
positive way they're less likely to be
depressed agreement and if you're not
depressed that's not a bad thing
but I think some people out there watch
One Tree Hill and whatever else and they
think if I'm not this dark character
this has some sort of angst to get to
where I am somehow my life's not valid
in some way they're having a bad day
they are there on the [__] bad day
there's someone in the back of that
ambulance he's having a much more
terrible day and that's not what I'm
saying I'm not saying someone having the
worst day from you so don't feel feel
lucky about yourself I'm you're saying
I'm finger to that line on bond or sings
on the Christmas thank God it's them
instead of you what coming just us for
it to be nobody but that ironic though
be ironic is he ironically singing no
he's not they actually had to change
light in the rear up of the what did
they change it to perm something like
yeah thankful you're not [__] bono a
[__] prick what should we talk about
never thing next up something slightly
less deep this one's called my special
fetish admit I'm looking for other sauce
finishing the year on a strong one
cheers to you cheers alone what you want
to call him Santa hi Santa
yeah he'd give us a little praise mister
so basically I've heard from one of my
mates that there's a girl who likes me
but I don't really like her even though
she's a solid seven
singing you can unlock a sudden I'm not
really interested in our body type as I
prefer the curvier bbw women also me to
me I think I much like me too I don't
think that was the real reason that was
started what we use in it
he's the bit I think I might have a
fetish for hairier women it just turns
me on a bit I've been with a hurry girl
before there's a girl who fits my agenda
you will expert Lily she shaved
everywhere if I've seen if I was seen -
got a shape she just did it really I was
like yeah you can just rock out or your
coat me shouldn't have a [__] but I just
mean like yeah you can do whatever you
want you know I mean like I would jam
out any climate I mean I'm not the type
of dude who if a girl's got a full bush
to be I wouldn't give a [__] to be
honest we're but I think she was a bit
conscious that other people see that she
was Barbara Bush you know immune but if
I was seen with her I think most of my
friends would make fun of me also I
don't think my mum what with the assume
were the servant returned yet no no
sorry I said the other girl though that
the Harrier girl that fits his agenda
he's got oh she is she is she there she
I guess so but I guess he says she's a
lesbo
I also ensues as a lesbian I also think
my friends would tell her that my
nickname is Heavy D because there's a
rumor going round that I've got a
micropenis right even though their mum
thinks otherwise I don't know what that
means sarcastically call me Heavy D so
there's a terrible rumor going around it
this is this guy's got a cocktail of
terrible things going on a he's got a
girl that likes him she's a seven out of
ten awful secondly he likes hairy fat
women or curvier women and see the woman
he likes a lesbian and D Heavy D look
it's got a micro no he doesn't they're
joking I mean I wouldn't worry about
that because that's obviously rubbish
what's gonna happen about that but how
would you dispel rumors of micro penis
you've dealt with this I would say a
[__] the girl the seven out of ten would
be my first thing why cuz they're
attracted to it but
huh mother hello over and then then
everyone will know right not everyone's
a sexual God that you are I'm not God
right just a demigod just a king right
not everyone's the sexual deviant
all right if you just want to [__] her a
hairy baby I'm not to be fair I mean
that there's bound to be girls out there
who are on the you know chubby hairy
side hairy all over I don't know where
the hair is that he likes
do you mind hair under the armpits I'm
not really keen on that I'd rather this
shave the the armpits what if she took
you no no but there are some girls who
have a little bit of hair on their arms
do you know when you're sitting there so
I'm a dinner table and you look at a
girl you're like especially if it's a
dark head the you notice it a lot more
do you not like that I don't care but
I'm just saying some people would I find
it weird when people think that body's a
hairless like even I remember Kim
Kardashian said once some like I'm a
[__] a really hairy woman because of
where I'm from like me she's from she's
Middle Easterners yeah yeah her family
bloodline ah anyway I think I seen but
some men insist women are hairless
apparently yeah cuz I've gone with girls
before and I've been like yeah just
shaved on shave I don't really give a
[__] or downstairs not and they're like
well you don't care and I'm like not
bothered and they and some man I put it
in now some men just insist that they
are like not a hair on them you know I
mean but then those men Harry is [__]
yeah hypocrites I'm sorry you know what
I'm thinking is maybe if you go on the
internet this bounderby girls out there
who will you just have to you know look
on the sites and that do you think you
should worry about what his friends
would say too if he did get with the one
that he caused a lesbo well if that's
his type and she's not a lesbian and
will go with him then who gives a [__]
what your mates think because you can
say I like her I really hate when may
take the piss out of one of them it's
for the girl that they're worth I think
that's [__] out of order however me
like I'm not being funny but if using
every single last you're going to [__]
your entire
gonna be a 10 and you're talking [__] do
you know what I mean and quite honestly
if she makes you [__] nut who gives a
[__] what your mates think about do you
really think that what do you not now
this is a big question do you know I
used to be this way I used to be this
way and that's what annoys me because I
was the same I remember when I was at
school there was a fat girl I fancied
and I was worried that my mates would be
like what you going with the fat girl
for hello I was quite chubby myself to
be fair but more chubby than I am though
and when I was meaning like only at
school I lost it to be fair it was after
oil then gained it Leah but I was
thinking I'm just gonna wait and I was
gone aren't you that I was tricking the
lords last night and I've realized I've
only had cereal no I'm on the foot what
can I say you have Coco Pops frost is
frostys Wow big man yeah but what I'm
saying right how old is he yeah he's be
16 he's not 16 his ID isn't put his
agent anyway I think I say this for all
lads out there don't ever take a piss
out with one ear me it's cuz he fancies
a girl who isn't your type be grateful
he doesn't want more you want less
competition right let you like each go
and get whatever you want
if he wants a [__] a fiery girl and I've
done that before
and it was like it was good she was
[__] great in bed she was an absolute
demon in bed go and [__] do it
general I mean I recommend it right
don't get me wrong because skinny
hairless girls are [__] just as good
right there or all women are just inside
wet and warm so who gives a [__] what's
on the outside that the idea right and
that I think is the overall message more
you take from today's podcast would you
I mean and as well that's one thing I've
got to say right now also just big dicks
kind of just said no some people think
cause a girl's fart that she's not going
to be tight one of the tightest girls
one of the tightest if not the tightest
girl I've ever been with was a fat girl
and
was Constantina so not calm right so
just saying don't judge a girl by
anything like that you know I mean right
I guess I've never really thought about
that but now I have there's two things
that made me feel horrific ly sick today
that guy fallin off the side of the
building and you talking about being
tight and wet and warm I couldn't
believe it I was shot I know he what
when you have insect Bailey hittin
honestly she was [__] tiny but she was
huge right she was a size 20 she was a
dress size 20 he's that big big isn't
just made me that's big that's
voluptuous I think is what you say that
as that was big but but that's you know
I've run with that she was great
it's just a comment it's just an
observation rather than a comment I mean
they're all smaller than me right yeah
what are you size 20 I've never tried to
woman's dress on but she certainly
wasn't 20 [__] forced or Brianna
Rihanna has gotten sick lately I'm like
than that I think that's just Instagram
edit thick thick girls do you think
though don't always justify you sex
about you good sex there's if you can
get with a partner who really gives you
really good sex you want that's yeah I
think value are in life of learned
jumping from girl a girl doesn't give
you the best scenario having a girl who
you can regularly have sex with who
knows you and you know her yeah to be
honest that's where you're gonna get
most of the best sex from so then
there's also the issue and here's part
of how do you deal with this that some
people in relationships always think I
get better sex than this and actually
what they don't realize is they're
having amazing sex right now I don't
know like if you're thinking you can get
better right what what do you mean right
if you think you can get better than the
related is the sector having isn't that
good probably
I understand to conversation with guys
where they've been I feel I can have
better sex and I'm having and you're
like well mate you know I think when you
the grass always greener I'm just saying
that I sometimes you get a bit bored of
what you're looking at
I think men especially if you're a porn
watcher you sort of get used to watching
this different girl every night and then
when you're having sex with a woman it's
the same girl over and over and over
again you get but I don't know I don't
really have bad sex generally because
good tonight with it I sort of I'm in
the driver seat mainly so I know what
I'm getting out the city where I'm at in
the car and I make sure that home
I'm putting it down
did you fix your car by the way the cars
fixed sadly I give up the old bm7 series
I really love that what I want to get
one you want air alright I wanna know
they are it's the dream car but I don't
know where I'll be to afford one can I
just check have you ever tried to fit
into an alright I have I think so
basically for those who don't know I I
took an RA for a test drive when I was
really poor and I just pretended like
I'd inherited money this is three weeks
ago it was it was 2011 Wow and I drove
around and I was like I [__] have one
of these one day and then I got out and
thought and I never will yeah I'm sorry
I'm late you threw the keys back the guy
and went see you later sucker I'm hoping
I could do what some of these YouTube
[__] have done and really milk YouTube
in the next few years and get one but I
don't know if I I need that so get on
the endicott you know what I mean
sidemen money I met this girl a few
months ago this is new email by the way
from Rudolph I met this girl few months
ago and we were talking regularly by
text and got on really well and were so
similar she goes to my school but it's
the year below I'm 16 in year 12 she's
15 in year 11 cattle night we met after
two weeks of talking and since then saw
each other nearly every weekend in the
same school and has a lit of fun
together I think it means bit look good
after a few weeks ago we made the
decision to be a to be official and she
became my girlfriend last week she told
me she had she was struggling to find
time for everything I love
teenagers go I'm really struggling to
find time for everything in my life all
these businesses doing you [__]
the between is we Mon Tree Hill and all
the [__] other teenage dramas I'm
finding a hard spend time with you and
transitioning away from Barbie dolls she
said nothing would change but she
recently told me she didn't know how she
felt anymore and has been really on and
off with me one day we all have good
conversations and joke around then the
next day she'll be really blunt with me
and seem like she doesn't want to talk
for me I've had girlfriends in the past
or I make don't brag but I've never
connected with someone like I did with
her I'm not sure what to do so here's
the truth MIT right because I don't want
to let this go but here's the truth
because I feel for this kid because
we've all been there it's hard it's hard
when it girl says to you I'm not feeling
you anymore you like so here's the truce
policy just so he knows she's hit you
right in there and you're falling in
love with her and you feel that
everything and all the butterflies and
all that [__] is coming on strong
against dying and you can't stop it but
the thing is for her it has stopped and
she doesn't like you that much get rid
of it do the January transfer let
Coutinho go to Barcelona do you know
what I mean basically yeah yeah you have
to find someone else maybe cuz she just
doesn't give a [__] I think and the
thing is what she does like she likes
the allure of like you know flirting and
all of that and some days she's gonna
have a flirt will you make herself feel
good because she knows you're desperate
for her no not at all she's just playing
around with him she's not that into him
get rid me you've got to move on to
another girl in fact a really good
analogy is actually football transfers
hmm when a player puts in a transfer
request let them go it's my advice or
sometimes you sell a cat in your yeah
right and you feel like you've let in
the world ego but stated on its way but
well maybe you know sigh you know young
up-and-coming player not too young
office but what I mean is someone with
potential yeah and then when you find a
player that commits for life a one club
man if you will commit to that watch you
know I've realized about me later on or
I don't always bring everything back to
me because almost in Eagle me
this 14-year old girl in the classroom
sitting on the floor watching someone
give a speech what I've realized is I
really don't like chess and women
anymore just a status no like if a girl
says things like I'll think about it
or if a girl messaged me and said I'll
think about it or maybe or suck it later
am I in certainly just that's it like
you know I mean yeah I thought II yeah I
turned I quite like being chaste and if
a girl wants me that's what I'll have
your avatars going to the little gray
headed man on whatsapp because she's
blocked yeah yeah no more from the
bribry proposed by what's up name is
Wray break Oh bye-bye huh so what you're
saying is move on move on kid let go to
Barcelona next one next one is Blitzen
so basically I went out with a guy is
that a girl it's cool oh my god loving
it loving it all right move on loving it
his name is Jake right let's pretend his
name is Jake and it went well but we
decided to take a break to focus on uni
applications and all that sort of stuff
in February earlier this year we went to
the same party but neither of us knew
anyone so we spoke then we kind of
started liking each other
you're aboard already everyone was gonna
everyone was everything was going well
and we were really hitting it off but no
one could know this is interesting it
was something only me and him could know
about a few weeks went by and my friend
let's call her snake told me that's not
a great name for a person it told me
that she liked Jake and and I was like
oh so me and Jake kind of kept speaking
because let's be real
she should have cleared this yeah go for
it sort of a weird but sort of a work
she got feeling like just as can I read
it
so me and Jake ethically because let's
be real she should have got feelings for
him anyways so now let's fast-forward
started telling the emotion we didn't
the emotion hope she started telling him
bad stuff about me that wasn't true so
that he think I was like a [__] person
and she could have him to herself
herself she started going out and she
told they started going out and she told
me she didn't want to be positive a more
and she'd rather be brotherly with him
when we on Friday they broke up and now
he keeps messaging me saying that he
liked me the whole time and he didn't
know it was all lies now he's asking me
to go with problem with him what do i do
I fancy the [__] out of him but I am NOT
a [__] many thanks I'm 18 years old
with 13 year old girl promise what she
signs off shout out her shout you know I
love the surname but shut out you Jay
I'm gonna call her JP she's even got her
email ease yeah mm-hmm anyway anyway
anyway yeah I say go to the problem with
him cuz it will really piss the other
girl and well same with his [__] high
didn't be just wear something good self
and she's 18 so weaknesses we're
something that just shows how good you
look
I feel good look good kisser in front of
a really [__] Rob solid one thing I
know feels really good is if you know
another girl fancies your guy kissing
him in front of them and the guy is
genuinely Sun in there like this is
great and you don't know cuz you're the
guy and you're all like you love me and
they're like yeah yeah sure I love you
anyway
are they looking yeah go for it and then
BAM you've gone back yeah and that
[__] snake can slither away and lick
the wounds snakes not cool organs should
be one more email one more yeah sure why
not
I'm looking for a good color well
there's a girl good another girl where
they're all that one that that's bizarre
booklet printing
so yeah it's not a big problem it's
basically booklet press is there anymore
good because I like the girl ones
because it's a boyfriend posted
that's from someone called oh cool
that's cool cool extract based boyfriend
I was caught we'll call her care yeah k
ex-boyfriend posted that he cheated on
me on Facebook hello love the bagua keep
keep me anonymous please sir vanadium
call me whatever you like I'm 17 and a
few months ago my boyfriend I broke up
on good terms due to the fact that we
were both leaving school for University
and traveling we stayed friends which
was all going fine until someone told me
that he was he cheated on me while we
were together with another girl I know I
ended up just letting this past as I'm
from a pretty boring area so people
often stir the pot when nothing has
actually heard and I didn't draw a
mother to start any unnecessary in a
friend group based on something someone
had said however a couple of nights ago
when my ex was out with his pals I saw a
post on Facebook by him and his friends
that said he cheated on me I'm pretty
pissed as you can imagine as this was
posted publicly for everyone I know to
see and they're making a joke out of
whatever he did despite the fact that
he'd support we were supposedly friends
should I talk to him to find out what
happened with this girl should I ignore
the situation and him and just move on
or should I just tell him he's a bit of
a [__]
any advice for both would be fab sorry
for all the whining you're not whining
you're right to email in sent from mail
for Windows 10 I think have dignity of
class ignore it move on yeah it's over
anyway but he sounds like just he's
alone one of these ways can you contact
tell them he's a [__] and [__] off look
dawn contact him don't call us we'll
call you
yeah and the best thing about it is the
basic sensitive but the best way to have
dignity is to know that person's done
wrong move on don't do wrong as well
an eye for an eye makes the whole world
should we do another you me like
so I'm off for another one while we're
waiting for the lads here all right
Olivia oh he's a made-up name
beat that out know that the oven she
hasn't said anything mother look just
cool skin is separated I'd like some
advice on how to maintain my
relationship me and my boyfriend have
been together for two years and I'm very
close with him and his friends he is
sorry by the way that previous person
the situation you're in sounds terrible
and I feel terrible that you've been
snaked by your friends that sounds
really bad we feel bad for you but know
that you're in the right he's a year
older than me and I'm going to
university next year while I'll still be
in college
he's only moving about 30 minutes away
however the college I to go to is in the
middle of nowhere and relies on an 8:00
a.m. to 3:00 p.m. bus to get there and
home this wasn't too much of an issue
when we both went there we go back to
mine this bus doesn't go Jesus problem
about a bus this wasn't no anywhere near
his uni and is the only bus but is the
only bus the area's problems we both
can't drive we both can't drive because
we can't afford it and I'm pretty sure
if I was allowed a car in a car he'd be
visiting me in prison instead of college
right okay because she run people down
I'm worried that we won't be able to see
each other as we can hardly afford
travel now moving in somewhere would be
an option but we definitely were
definitely not ready for that and we
can't afford it I could move College
however this basic what she's saying is
they're not close to each other where
they're studying what should she do the
bus isn't a convenient one bad buses can
you believe someone's actually wrote
that in for me
I mean believe I'm supposed epochs I
mean what am I supposed to do get on
another [__] bus service and say yeah
we've got a [__] problem
Aretha yeah you need to put on another
bus service why well there's a young
love true Geordie said so tell me mail
us back tell us how much the that's the
bottom line because true Georgie said
saw em email us back tell us how much
they this one's a good one maybe
building muscle honest how much do you
want how much money do you need
so you mail me that yeah how much money
do you need and we'll see if we bring
the response start a GoFundMe maybe it's
important while this is along I'm not
listening to this so you know it's not
that long it's just it's in you know in
school where you try and fill more pages
so you make the font bigger how you
stole from me problem because we've got
a lot of waffles to do okay my problem
isn't about girls so you can switch off
if you want
Geordie Elsie you switch off if you want
Geordie this is my last year in high
school and let's just say my work ethic
has pretty much made this year made this
last year a bit of a redeeming year to
get got the grades I need for my future
but basically my question is I am
completely [__] in life if I don't
achieve national five maths national
five maths is what is called in Scotland
don't know what it is in England
probably in a basically what he's saying
is mass is the only subject I am having
difficulty with I appreciate your advice
he really doesn't understand maths also
Lawrence you're genuinely one of the
funniest people I've ever come across
your slide comments get me every time
smiley face so he wants to do an
apprenticeship in a trade of some kind
after high school yeah is what he soon
yeah what kind of trade would you take
up that's the second no what's he asking
national [__] maths go to you teacher
and say I'm really struggling with this
and I feel like I could do with some
extra help what
how did we go to Robbie Williams to this
Robbie watching missing going Russian
IVs watching it going [__] [__]
revised me move on how are you doing a
little yeah sure used to do as many as
you want teenage foursome what the [__]
no way no way
hi my name is Donna and I have a dollar
to blot it's a blog month yeah Donna
like donner and blitzen the [__]
ranges it's Donna over Indiana yeah
Donner Blitzen I think he all right
I actually think Donna's not in the room
but I think Blitzen Donner and Blitzen
is actually a thunder and lightning
latinum : as in calling beer that ain't
really a problem got I didn't really
thought about my close mate just started
hitting it on with a girl
[__] within a week I'm close to him
and the girl's best friend I went round
and started joking about inviting them
round and seeing what happens he started
talking about it and then text the girl
he [__] and genuinely arranged it with
me him and the two other girls I've
already done [__] with girls that never
had sex and I don't know if I should
start with a force but my best mates
house [__] me we're both not that
innocent when it comes to girls you are
probably even perfect warm on your Duff
Claire but I still don't know what to do
hope you read this and get to hear about
this in your podcast imagine if you
pause the podcast something goes guys
let's just chill I have a little for
some listen to the true joys I not sure
the thought out me just a little end of
your podcast retreat you I would never
normally talk someone out of having sex
but you don't sound like you sure if
you're having a foursome for your
virginity it's probably not ideal like
you know I mean it yeah virginity should
not be hitting a [__] room full of
peace is the way his I imagine it will
go right two seconds and he'll go up
come already you guys just get on with
it
the thing is when I lost my virginity ah
you and I had the opposite problem
I [__] lasted forever forever i
weirdly because I had a condom on I
couldn't feel [__] also I'm just [__]
giving it hell and I'm like you're
looking here in the eye and I'd rather
read it went well pretty much yeah
so I mean may just just find a girl that
you just want to be alone with her and
do that first for Gracie just do it with
one girl first just start with one and
then we evolve or G yes what you want
and also let's just be clear
most men I'd say yeah most men I've
never seen a another man's penis during
a sexual situation I don't want to yeah
it's not really the rosing sort of we've
completely overlooked that that his
mates gonna be there and they're both
gonna see each others just the thing is
I don't I don't like it's not that it
would bother us that much it's just you
know I'd rather be me and the two girls
I also think you should wait until you
are the right it's the right time in
your life if you're thinking about
having sex at the teenage point in your
life don't don't rush like yeah and also
be comfortable with your cell and
confident a to [__] like this me you are
nowhere near prepared for this it's like
you're going into a [__] gun fight
with a foot and unarmed also if you're a
teenager and you're thinking having a
force and the likelihood is the parents
downstairs just going what are they
doing up there I just go up and have a
quick check what the [__] yeah I'm sure
that they've thought about this [__] cuz
you know what do teenagers are like and
you also know what parents are like
where they go two boys two girls
upstairs your virginity just do it one
girl for [__] sake mate
next one I recently found out that my
mum is cheating on my dad she's ours
really I don't think my dad knows this
is a really strong problem Bible can we
just say that this is the worst or
because at least at least with a bloke
you're like do you mind but you sort of
and it's a double standard beaten theory
you can sort of get away with that you
know I mean cause it's like men have
their needs the one women are little
innocent mother you know she's probably
40 or whatever she's none the wiser
but with a woman it's like [__] what
yeah you know I mean you horrible piece
you are the word [__] hungry
milf look here Sullivan ting at the lips
other than littlest bit of [__] God
now who comes past you're just going for
it
come more this launch Adventist pig I
don't think my dad knows but I don't
know what to do should I speak to him
should I speak to my mum should I tell
no one any help would be great you know
he's funny I was open the bar the other
night and then this girl was like I'm a
FEMINIST and I was like I'm a male
chauvinist pig so it's fine and as soon
as I said that the look at her eyes
changed from what I knew she liked it
straightaway
I just [__] knew it like people can
say whatever they want they could say oh
you know Giggsy got pork that's always
saying I could tell the fact that I was
such a challenge was an instant
attraction
honestly daddy's daddy been cheated and
mummy doesn't want anyone to know how do
we solve this movies getting blasted
with calm blast this must be quite a
traumatic situation for a rose so much
ignore not look like mom's getting
[__] dick
that is bad doesn't it [__] and we're
just drinking champagne oh Christ on a
bike just to me I thought of as have a
bike did he find out or by walking in on
her maybe although maybe saw the car
maybe she was her all-fours literally
getting to him that obviously not what
it says in the email now this kids found
out about his mum cheating on his dad
does he goes whose mum first and go mum
the five go to the mum
but then the mum goes I'll buy you an
Xbox if you don't tell your dad
oh it's an open Xbox and there's the
yeah but then your mom if your schewe it
and you haven't really given us so much
detail but if you're sure I show up and
be make sure you get the Kinect maybe a
package sort of forza and fifa in there
well well you don't want to do pop geez
and this is the way I would approach the
situation because I'm an open and honest
person right if you caught the mother
what you're giving her chance to do was
cover our trucks hide it from your dad
and also the mother can then say to to
dad about you and blame on you or make
out that you're a liar and give her time
to prepare for this if you go to the dad
he might not react well he might lash
out or you might freak out I have a
meltdown
what'd you give me that going dad just
let me do what what I would do
personally is knitted in it well not
quite but almost I would say it in front
of the pair of them what's going on
again what's gone on yeah I would say
I'll bring up and say mom I've noticed
whatever what whatever evidence that
you've got say well what what happened
in here maybe try and get some photos of
you mum having said what you're saying
what you want to do is summon the true
GB have yeah truTV problems at gmail.com
yeah to us we'll see the photos of mum
getting done doggystyle I don't want to
see those anything will verify if it's
all sex yeah and then when we say yes
then you know she's [__] right you
saying only penetrative sex is cheating
what what do you think it's cheating
do you know I mean is mum going down to
the bar is she having a bit too much
flirting well either this conversation
ruses do you think that messaging other
people is cheating yeah
do you think that because that not the
answer you want it no no all right
but some people seem to think that only
when you [__] someone is that then
cheating there's an emotional side to it
as well I think that people and I think
at the same time there's different
levels of cheating it's all there is
levels to the ship but at the same time
all cheating is cheating but
at the same time I think sometimes when
people are unhappy in a revolution we're
plus some cheating is what I'm saying
like for example currently if you
message other people and you don't [__]
there's still hope left in the
relationship right I think once you go
and your [__] other people then it's
it's it's [__]
so penetrative cheating is bad so
depending on what evidence you've got I
think you should bring it up in front of
them yeah and so look so there you are
at dinner
Oh mum what a lovely I know I'm asking
I'm sure what I would do but this this
is the thing I don't know if you're
capable of having the balls to do that
because it takes a lot but it's the
safest option because then you can leave
that they discuss it and they both know
and remove yourself from the situation
where if you start saying one thing the
one and one to the other you become a
part of it you become the middle bit no
and you don't really put on and let drop
that bomb leave them to deal with it and
get the [__] out oh I see you've caught
on yeah you get your card and you're
like just about quote mom dad there's
something that you use Bohr should know
before I leave
mum's having an affair right I'll say
okay I'll see you okay do this win an
arcade in this town for ten years Jimmy
see ya bye yeah or mid dinner you just
go mum this chicken breast lovely one
more thing my wife loves oh but I don't
agree that I knew word-plays right and
and then she goes what don't you clear
within the workplace Jimmy and then you
go cheating mum Merry Christmas sue
Buster's now what we're taking the boat
out not over the Christmas the Christmas
dinner you go mum I noticed you were do
you put your some dick last week and
then dad goes excuse me what I noticed
I'm just I'm just having this lovely
picking I read take and plug it and I
notice that John from next door has
picking your bloody floor mum mum why
would you allow that pig into your
blanket and all your gravely got on his
Pig yeah mum why don't you come all over
this big that don't ya grandma's already
yeah
yeah I'm getting really drunk by the way
you've got a business just to be just to
be very clear this kids having a really
traumatic time is like just taking the
piss out of them for five minutes when
you come to me for advice I still think
you'd give him good advice there sit
them down together we drop the bomb and
then [__] off brilliant dream girl at
work this one seems like well this is a
good one all right this one is from -
yeah can I can I can I Cherie yeah brief
this alright he's 16 he's a virgin and
he's had several sexual experiences 100%
sexual received oral few times but he's
never had full sex you still think he's
a virgin even if he's received oral for
me yeah if you haven't had full sex to
me you're still kind of a virgin the
body of Christ and I am NOT awkward
sexually is racing right I've got a job
at a restaurant first shift he meets
this girl
come let's call her Sophie and as soon
as I saw her I knew I had instantly
fallen in love Wow can I was sweet to be
fair I've I've been there as a young man
when you see a girl who saw beautiful
but can I just say me you haven't fallen
in love with her you haven't fallen in
love why you have you're infatuated you
are blown away by how hot this girl is
she's not that you don't even know
anything about at this point so what
happens is you're sort of where your
hormones and all the [__] going on
your brain anybody is convincing you
that you're in love with that you're not
you don't even know our property even
love you idiot will the same age live in
the same town friends with some of our
college friends in common we chat a bit
of work but not to the amount where I
can be confident that there it's because
she likes me having stuff GA track
generative signs that she might find me
attractive for example followed on
Instagram she added me on snapchat also
the second time I met her she then
mentioned that one of her best friends
remembers me from school Wow such sinus
yeah one of my best friends from school
no they say mumble Bakshi gun was either
talking to me about talking to her
friends about me or she sought me on
social media and so we had mutual
friends
Willian am i looking too much these fine
details in a way maybe not and that's
the truth maybe not right maybe not
because details are what girls drop
right
and they go oh let's see if he picks up
on this back to the witch's cottage my
question is should I talk to her twerk
on me for the same to become more
obvious or message her on snapchat
commit you are an Amish hat in this [__]
meaning what city gain because I but why
you messaging me me you should be
message in her right now do you know me
do you think you should send this email
to her how do I play if I get rejected
and work becomes really awkward just put
here send it to her and go got a little
bit of a problem me I've had girls
reject me before lord x this [__]
happens
he put PS i'm decent-looking and most
girls raped me as 6 - no sorry 8 - 9 out
of 10
Wow but I'm 5 foot 9 no bad luck turn of
your 5 foot name pole you've gotta pay
up - isn't it's your you've got a bit
least a 6-footer to be an 8 pretty much
yeah if you're below that don't even
bother thinking you're in a because you
are not going anywhere
to be fair there are some handsome mean
Tom Cruise's 5/7 yeah but anyways you
will still find them but what I would
say is he has how you feel oh yeah so
you feel a situation now go to it work
go there's no order at table 5 by the
way I love you see it it's a party dick
and she goes what and he goes they want
spotted dick over there just custard and
cream for the other one thank you I love
you what just to get them the table
spicy sausage on on the piece on the
table like what so what yeah not to be
like olive bread what why are you saying
garlic olive bread I love you what why
are you doing this in
I'm trying to save the date in front of
a table pal be brilliant when you're
mustered in this girl I love you Kirsty
what nothing
mix small talk but eventually there's a
good rule of thumb you listen there's a
good [__] rule of thumb compliment
her yeah not straight away a lot of when
you serve those dishes I have a bit
small talk come on I said something like
you look really nice silver do whatever
I saw the way Table five gave you a big
tip that's a nice apron specifically if
you're on Instagram for example say
something about one of her pictures yeah
you look really good man this primum I
was a master of Instagram if anything
like my relationship but I'm you know
didn't you know best relationship ever
had we started on Instagram all right
and you can you can do so much I mean
look this is the thing so what I'm
trying to say is if you pinpoint only
just know it
you look great in this picture if she
then doesn't compliment you back at all
which is kind of how it usually goes
don't at me then you you work a little
harder but if if you get nothing if
you're saying oh you saw did it like and
don't come across as a wet blanket
obviously but if you pay a few
compliments and you get nothing back
thought a before we head tonight next
time you're at works here don't forget
to wash that [__] dish I've seen you
miss that up yeah yeah and then she
knows you're in the driving seat no in
all seriousness if she doesn't give you
any compliments but and you're sort of
pouring it on a bit yeah it's a waste of
time waste of time
just let her get the tip from the table
and just move on just seeing that I've
seen your big tits I mean big tips that
you I see the way that you use those men
on those we do another one yes obviously
you see I'm actually enjoying the
scenery using the keyboard shortcuts you
jealous sure Joshua you wanna know so
you talk tell him to ring the buzzer and
then I'll run up now
anyway I just want to say merry [__]
Christmas everyone yeah and a happy new
year 2018 is my year every year is my
[__] year all right we're gonna do
this it's all coming stay tuned all that
[__] but have a good tub of the time
with your families lots of gravy and if
you're not with your families then have
a good time wherever you are alone don't
if you're just spending it with us
Thanks if you don't have a family and
that's all so people watch us on
Christmas tears are part of like the
thing do you know Tommy hey grandma look
at this for a second summer your eyes
Merry Christmas
like the video stays subscribed we love
you thanks for watching and we'll say as
Leia